les trois candidatures proposées pour la
succession de françois molins sont
toutes trois étaient écartés en dépit
d'un grand oral passer devant le premier
ministre ce rejet sonne comme une
mauvaise manière faite à ses magistrats
et comme un désaveu pour vous mêmes nous
vous savons très préoccupé par le
vaudeville de la place beauvau et les
portes qui claquent
malgré tout madame la ministre
pouvez-vous nous rassurer sur
l'indépendance de la justice
pouvez-vous nous garantir la crédibilité
du futur procureur de paris
l'article 20 de la constitution qui
précise que le gouvernement détermine et
conduit la politique de la nation
monsieur le sénateur du rhin quel autre
politique plus importante que la
politique pénale ne vous rejoint pas
dans cet article 20 il est donc tout à
fait naturel que les procureurs de la
république soient situées sous une
autorité dans une chaîne hiérarchique
est sous l'autorité du premier ministre
cela me semble tout à fait évident
comment imaginer que sur un poste aussi
important qui a en charge le plus grand
parc et de france qui a en charge des
questions extrêmement sensible il y est
j'ai répondu il y est il n'y ait pas de
dialogue entre les autorités
vous avez parlé de la réforme
constitutionnelle nous en attendons
calendrier il faut garantir
l'indépendance de la justice il faut
rompre le lien entre votre ministère et
le parquet donc quand ce calendrier de
révision constitutionnelle nous
sera-t-il données
comment pouvez vous pensez faire croire
après ses démêlés avec le président de
la république que le ministère le
ministre de l'intérieur est en mesure
d'exercer pleinement ses fonctions
avez vous conscience monsieur le premier
ministre que les français ne veulent
plus de ces mises en scène mais qu'ils
attendent de la sincérité et des
résultats monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur collomb va t-il oui ou non qui
viennent le ministère de l'intérieur
oui les ministres doivent se consacrer
pleinement à leur tâche c'est la raison
pour laquelle dont le gouvernement que
j'ai l'honneur de diriger
aucun des membres du gouvernements ne
dirigent un exécutif local
vous reconnaîtrez avec moi madame la
sénatrice vous reconnaîtrai avec moi
madame la sénatrice que ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas ni dans le
gouvernement ou dans le quinquennat
précédent
né dans le gouvernement dit dans le
quinquennat précédent je considère
madame la sénatrice
je considère par dose
je ne vous voyait plus je vous considère
je considère madame la sénatrice que
l'implication et la concentration d'un
ministre qui sert le gouvernement qui
sert son pays qui sert ses concitoyens
doivent être entière c'est d'ailleurs ce
qu'a dit gérard collomb il y a deux
semaines lorsqu'il a indiqué qu' il
considérait que lorsqu'il sera en
campagne
il devrait quitter le gouvernement
reconnaissez avec moi madame la
sénatrice que cette attitude n'a pas
toujours été celle de responsable
ministériel qui était par ailleurs
candidat à des élections
aux termes de l'article 21 de la
constitution le premier ministre dirige
l'action du gouvernement
toute l'action du gouvernement et jamais
madame la sénatrice je ne laisserai le
début du commencement d'une hésitation
pointé sur ce sujet le premier ministre
dirige l'action du gouvernement aux
termes de l'article 8
il lui revient de proposer au président
de la république la nomination ou la fin
de fonction d'un certain nombre de
ministres de l'ensemble des membres du
gouvernement je prendrai mes
responsabilités et j'aurai l'occasion de
faire au président de la république
les propositions que les dispositions
constitutionnelles prévoit et réserve au
premier ministre je vous remercie
[Musique]